[Music]
yeah we are live baby
[ __ ]
welcome to the lions den the lions den
by money lion
man we're here with the boys forget your
intro we're at the super bowl we're at
the super bowl and we're at mike type
mike you got a nice house man thanks for
having me
this is a beautiful great house man i
got it on the market you're interested
in buying it
how much how much i take 12 bucks
[Laughter]
lenny kravitz had something to do with
it i think they designed it that's what
they said
i guess they want me doing the intro but
i feel like i mean come on right direct
to my left daniel cormier light
heavyweight champion heavyweight
champion analyst extraordinaire ufc
brandon marshall all pro badass
podcast game
and now now i'm i'll give out your other
accolades with you know but really
you're done the heavyweight the better
heavier weight in the world oh wow ufc i
just we talking about unifying the
divisions if you want to go boxing and
there's a conversation between is boxing
on it down or is it ufc on the up it
doesn't matter i'll take on cormier i'll
take on mike tyson well you come right
here yeah
we'll see what's up at half time
the man all the way at the end the
legend the one the only
iron mike tyson thank you yeah thanks
for having us brother appreciate it man
oh love
appreciate you so listen the big the
bangles are going to kill these guys
okay you think the banker's going to get
that money on me oh wow you got a lot of
money money on anything why are you why
are you so sure mike i feel dangerous
that feels dangerous
but mike this is this is where it it
it's a conflict of interest because i'm
a rams fan but now i know you got all
this money on it i can't root again if
you put all this money on it hey it's
the whole is about the excitement of the
game yeah i feel you you're no ram fan
you're a broncos fan don't pull this
[ __ ] on us though don't do this i live
in los angeles [ __ ] that now i'm around
i've been there twelve years but still
you didn't like this before they got
this good no you're right
what do you think you're doing listen
they come out the rams right now are
coming out conservative that's what
three running plays in a row
you know they're trying to ease into the
game
nerves you know this man nerves are high
how many times you had millions of
people watching you see this one right
here henderson come on he's a former new
orleans singer oh my god he's like
greatness you expect greatness
right look at him in cincinnati yeah
getting the second little guy moved up
big guys but you was a little guy you
was a little guy moving big guys know
that don't matter exactly that's why i'm
gonna play yeah
there you go
there you go
there you go
you gotta think about leaving what mike
just said you know he's talking about
little guy moving a big guy
yeah don't matter it's about your
technique it's about your feet work this
is what's there all right when they got
the statistics they say six five six was
crazy
they can't how do you measure the heart
and the will you can't do that
so all that's [ __ ] so tell us how do
you how do you do it if you see a
fighter you see a football player how do
you measure their heart their will how
do we do that you do that by their
dedication look at that dedication i
can't really hear what they're willing
to do in the other play tonight i can't
hear mike at all man
hey brandon let me ask you this
who would you rather have played for he
got stafford who's obviously bombs over
baghdad just joe burrow or joe burrow
joe bar i'm right away i'm going run
baby look at the movie yeah because
think about like um
i love his swagger
you know and i also he can do it all i
mean his football iq is through the roof
he can make every throw on the field but
i need a i need a quarterback that's
also gonna
go out to dinner with me i need a
quarterback that's also going to come to
the crib and chill have you ever played
with a quarterback that did that for you
yeah jay cutler was one ryan uh ryan uh
uh uh
fitzpatrick love ryan russell wilson i
had a couple of guys but but to see the
the things with me i had 17 different
quarterbacks 17 17
can't really build that relationship
wait two minutes you know
brenda let me ask a question
the rams just came off conservative
here's my i always wondered about this
in football they get they get the third
long and they always run the ball right
why
it's like they don't try to get the
first down because statistics right like
you know
when we go wednesday we sit down and we
put in our we start putting our game
plan thursday is when we do third down
okay so thursday we're only working on
third down and we're looking at third
and short what is third and short first
and first of three yards uh third and
medium six to seven third and long ten
eleven so we're putting in three or four
points you never wanna be in third and
long because statistically speaking like
you're only going to convert those
probably ten percent of the time right
so
you don't wanna make a bad situation
worse you don't want to go out there and
throw and get an interception it makes
the game worse so what we do we do draws
we do screens yeah every single time
every single time it's a statistic
we're looking at the numbers yeah
conversion to be really good on third
down we need to be converting and these
are super bowl teams and both of them
are
50 of the time we need to be converting
on third down yeah but that's
the problem is like because everybody
does the same thing they never get third
down very right because every time you
throw the screen they they're ready for
it yeah but you're looking at we know
that going in we know these screens and
these run plays it's all good we're just
trying not to make the situation worse
okay but if it's third and short oh yeah
we're getting after if it started medium
we're getting after third and long
most teams are saying
we'll live to see another another series
mangoes bango bang girl
now i'm stressed out now i gotta root
for the [ __ ] baby
baby we're gonna do it the underdogs
yeah can you put it up for me
can you hear it through the air yeah
yeah you've been here through a year no
we you know getting cold they got
[ __ ] at that mercy naked all the time
get cold for us we gotta go in the cold
and get some life they're giving out
some cash too man my friends have money
line download the money line app right
now get your
money war tag going that's my
every quarter a hundred grand man with
money line make money watch super bowl
with this download
i can make a bet every quarter
you're going to make a bet every quarter
mike is this possible yeah you go over
your bingos that go joe right here joe
burrow
joe
lsu
lsu's
mike talk to me about mindset you know
why they're going to win the game
because the other team came out ran the
ball three times in a row
and they came out throwing
because they can't get democratic
because they're holding them to
conservation are you always fighting
when y'all fighting do y'all ease into
the fights or are y'all coming out
i don't know right out of there
i was short
so i had to kind of attack people right
right i was i was the team that didn't
have the the talent right i was the kid
i was the guy that needed to go and put
pressure on people
because if i stand back i was fighting
that light heavyweight in heavyweights
right dude
but also
but also for dc
if you rush and you try to blitz these
seasons
so the thing was they would try to stay
on the outside so i would have to be the
advancing party because if not they're
kind of just picking me chipping me
three yards
but think about this situation though
right now you got the la rams they got
all the biggest stars in the world and
they came out playing conservative right
yep you got the cincinnati bengals yeah
and they come out and did they get the
first down first down didn't get
to me that says a lot about their
mindset
yeah but now now they're getting
momentum so i'm gonna third down now
they're gonna put right i'm gonna use a
little more loosey this time a little
more loosey-goosey and then also
what i love about the rams you gotta
decide are you gonna double cooper cup
who's the best achievement in the nfl
i'm gonna leave old el beckham
one-on-one you know what i'm saying
that's right that's a good deal that's a
great point
you gotta think about this you can't you
can't and this is where matthew stafford
had to do a phenomenal job of protecting
the football and making the right
decision oh they're going for it on
fourth down guys
that's what i'm talking about listen
though and they're throwing the ball oh
he forced it in the chase ramsey
and he forced it in the chase
he never looked at anybody else
he didn't look at him
he looked at chase the entire time
they [ __ ] fat but they don't [ __ ] long
okay
yo he looked at chase the whole time the
whole time running back people that was
wide open yeah they're running back in
them
brandon this one yeah you said you'd
rather play for joe burr i know he's a
great quarterback if you play for the
rams we had cooper cup on the other side
no you're getting one-on-one coverage
ding ding ding well go back to 2018
brandon why are you going to the giants
why because odell beckham is over on
this yeah
he's gonna get double now i'm gonna be
backside one on one so it's exactly what
you said what do you do if you're a
defensive coordinator but the
interesting thing about this match-up is
that they're not playing a lot of
man-to-man they're gonna play zone so
they're not gonna go and match up and
yeah they gotta
they gotta lean coverage they gotta take
out odell
cooper cup double him on third down
double odell on first down oh wow
because
that was the big play cooper cup is
gonna beat each other no no no no they
both big play both of those bigfoot
is something we've never seen like the
49ers that last week like come on how
does that happen come on bro what the
[ __ ] were the db's doing for the night
come on man how do you get beat that bad
oh my goodness i don't smoke
take
[Laughter]
the poison from frogs you still messing
with them frogs
the psychedelic frogs every day every
time i get a chance
why are you taking it it make you like
you know
i got a buddy that he loves it
he's just like it took him on a trip
that he's never like he will tell
everybody about it now really he is
literally the spokesperson for doing
that so so you seem like a button but i
was i'm like i'm not doing it it's not
in my personality that's not because i
don't know
if i'm end up running around like butt
ass naked
crazy [ __ ]
and then espn gonna be called like yeah
[Laughter]
they're like yo you're not even running
through l.a you're running through san
jose but has negative on the street look
at him right he locked in on chase the
whole time
take the flat you only need one
and you see ramsay them dudes all they
they they bracketed that was an iffy
call i don't know if you can make that
call this early in the game
here's the thing i think it speaks to
the mentality of the teams right because
cincinnati's not supposed to be here now
they're not building right playing with
house money they're playing with houses
yeah let's go baby go fill that hole
they're playing with house money yeah no
running
it's like
the rams are built to win today
they're built to win today we're stacked
but not
not the uh
the bengals aren't supposed to be no
because living in l.a the ram every rams
game is on yeah they take games off
they're so talented yeah they just take
games off
yo
hurt and uh
that didn't look good just now
yeah
i don't like how they protect the
quarterbacks so much now the tom brady
rule this this whole they don't let
these dudes tackle the quarterbacks at
all
well they're pretty even when you're
falling like you could fall and like
fall into the guy's legs a little bit
that's a penalty
it's bad that's not good
third and fourth let's go rams all right
here we go so where are we at we got
third and four this is short this is
third and short you're talking about
what seventy percent of the time you're
going to see one on one
okay like let's see do we have
one-on-one coverage so now you got
stafford looking at cooper cup as his
number one option come on cooper cupping
come on
come
on listen think about this this is what
make this guy special he wasn't even the
number one option right here but he
caught the ball behind the sticks and he
made a guy miss we call that yak daddy's
daddy's yard
oh my goodness look at this but look
that's the difference right that's the
difference in stafford and burrow burrow
he wasn't the number one option bro was
long chase this dude went through he
just moved on got it
that's right
[Music]
receivers in detroit where you know
calvin johnson those guys one year
removed big [ __ ]
so much
all right here we go with the situation
we're in the red zone right now it's
second to six this is the perfect time
for a run okay perfect time for a run or
you just throw a quick game quick game
is anything five yards or less
because you guys come on get him get the
[ __ ] get out go back he's gonna go pick
up three four we're good
so the reason why this is good we call
this
we're we're
we're in we're in we're in routine we're
on pace we're just trying to get on the
board right now the only thing we're
trying to do on offense let's go back
it's trying to get to third and short
third and manageable
that's it there you go so now you're
third and three you need to be
converting 33 at like 70
70
conversion
these are the things that we think about
and now we work through throughout the
week people think we just go out there
and play football we go out there and
play football it's like we spend more
time studying
than we do actually practicing i don't
play football in the morning right not
in practice all right here you go we got
empty formation three by two cooper cup
one on one what is up doing cooper jump
about to get a touchdown oh oh dude
oh oh no do
he's incredible why is he incredible
because listen he's the consummate
professional you know every time you see
him he's constantly
[Laughter]
catching the first touchdown that's big
my boy mike talking great job old dale
mike's so chill i can barely hear him
yeah
you got to talk louder
what we smoking what you smoking what
you smoking oh where'd it come from i
got my zone
yeah
i always see you posting that about
whiskey
all kinds of different ones here's the
question are we still on right now
are we still rolling all right good
here's the question
do you roll your own blunts
or do somebody else you have a guy
mike he's a full-time job he is the guy
that makes hundreds
of rolling blocks mike
you guys
mike
what's his or her name what's her name
troy troy
is he good at what he does
best ever
what makes a good uh uh blunt and roller
uh mike don't smoke blood to smoke
joints
periodically free rolls
no um i have my own drink on my own
blunts
mike tyson man got a his own roller no
you have to look up tyson 2.0
what's tyson 2.0 it's the biggest league
cup in the world
the biggest weed company in the world
check it out man i got them in 18 states
i know you know i guys in 18th state
listen mike's the elon musk and weed
really yeah but the the coolest thing
about fighting is that it's two seconds
you do mushrooms
i'm on my shoes now
i'm high right now well educate the
people how do we see you know the
science behind it mike you know the
science you got you're educated why is
this stuff important to you
it's a connection and the connection
with the divine leadership you have a
connection with god
mike doesn't it does that bring you down
a level two like you run at 10 when
you're on psychedelics it makes you more
human they could [ __ ] with you really he
could [ __ ] with you make you
it could it could build you up and stop
bringing some some grimy [ __ ] bring some
grimy demons from the past yeah
do you have gumshoe baby hey we're
sitting here
we go
my
three champions
what's good baby hopefully uh hopefully
now those demons come out mike you start
attacking people not today
hey mike you ever get too high and like
tigers and [ __ ] still or no say what you
ever get too high and make crazy
purchases
no
absolutely man i know what's that what's
the what's the craziest purchase you've
made over the last two years
because you've been in your bag the last
two years i've been good i've been doing
that but like um
buy property you're buying businesses
now yeah that's an investment though
[Applause]
listen think about how amazing that is
right the mike tyson to me when you talk
about i got my own roller but then you
go back to with mike tyson the big crib
and the lions and the tigers in the back
whatever
and now we made rolls-royce a legendary
story going through the through the toe
a dude didn't have a car and mike said
here take my keys it was a rolls-royce
is that true oh listen to this one
that's a true story no
no no it happened
i was um
i was married the first time i'm only 21
years old married my wife i go into a
restaurant my wife a fat food drink very
hungry she goes in my pocket to get the
money she pulls out some condoms
she gets in my car the rolls royce and
she rams it into some other car breaks
the guy's arm right
and so
all of a sudden she's screaming the cops
come up
i don't want the cops to lock up so the
guy's saying my arm is broken right my
arm is broken
the first guy gave him some money
stacking my mother ten thousand i'll
take it
he went into off track bet and started
betting and one guy came up and said oh
my arm is broken and i told the cops
you can have this man it's all good i
got too much [ __ ] you guys work hard to
risk your life take the car and when the
guy said
sir my arm is broken hey i'm telling you
one more [ __ ] time to [ __ ] out my
face
said that
cuz he hurt that car once he said once
he did that i thought i know i'm out of
it i didn't want my wife to get arrested
she just broke [ __ ] the guy up ran into
the car who was the wife at the time
what's her name you know [ __ ] robin
gave me yeah
she's your mic
hey my boy crazy right yeah
this is what i love about you and your
journey mike is that okay boom that's
where we were 20 30 years ago but now
you talk about disposable income and now
you're buying properties and businesses
and you're talking about your own
marijuana company right
so listen no listen
if you don't have nothing worth losing
all that [ __ ] you don't have nothing
right you have to have something that's
worth tearing yourself down right
all right here we go get back to
football third and fourth did i teach
you now now
uh
you know what you know what joe burl's a
little flustered he's a little off no
you didn't get started yet
all right fellas remember we're giving
away 25k a quarter that's a hundred
thousand dollars in the super bowl
download the money lion app right now
we're giving away 25 bangles bangles
come on bangla like money might give
every city that comes from mike that's
all my personal bank account come on
he's not trying hard enough they had
they had what they wanted yep you got
one-on-one what did i say
you're going to get one-on-one coverage
mono imano 70 of the time yup they got
exactly what you they wanted
and he didn't hit it
the running back got caught up he got
tripped but he had it now we call that a
big box fade it was perfect let's feel
like in the same way you gotta
capitalize
that was just a situation where the
running back feet got tangled with the
say right i linebackers
mike might be about to give up
nah good night's out still how about
that [ __ ] yeah it's just started it
just started starting
rounds that's right see he used to go
what is it three we only got five yeah
25 minutes that's the difference it's
different these dudes go 36.
that 36 minutes is is a nightmare right
but the three minute round three minute
rounds but listen though i feel like the
three-minute round makes you want to
fight harder because it's shorter but
they they don't really get started six
rounds
mike mike what was the mentality going
into round 10 11 12.
i'm gonna wear this guy now
trying to wear the other guy there when
he got late yeah avoid as many punches
as possible of course
punch into the body for the body hey
mike let me ask you this you know tyson
fury and francine
pretty sure they're gonna fight a year
from now they're going to fight how's
that go down with francis and tyson fury
oh man no bro hey you know what's crazy
hold on i can't everything let me just
say this before mike answers let me just
say this mike you better not give me a
company answer bro i listen no shut
up listen
bro watching watching the fight
against uh cyril chirogun i'm watching
it and i'm thinking to myself love
francis
can't box will tyson fury
absolutely listen
you had a blown out mcl 24-0
24-0
he had an mcl acl
right leg
three weeks before the fight still be he
out he you know he took his heart he
took cyril's heart a little bit because
listen right
man for man he can't beat cyril
he can't beat him in a straight up fight
free fight man for man he got to get him
he had to rough him up
he can't fight that guy head up no he's
there for losing games mike but that's
part of the fight to take down yeah but
you love the takedown because when
you're standing you come up out of your
seat you jump but i know there's a point
you know and i know he can't fight this
guy mike jumped there with michael he
can't fight that guy heading up like
that i'm looking directly at my my jump
out of the seat and went crazy up in
there
so you boys don't want to see francis
with tyson i just think that a box
francis of course i want to see it yeah
of course i want to watch it but i'm
just saying i don't know france don't
make a lot of money that's what we want
yes
france will make a ton of money i just
want no people don't know this boxing
[ __ ] is tricky why is it true
i go like that i said listen do this put
them in there with a
a golden gloves or a national champion
the heavyweight division no we need
money just let them smile with spar with
them we need money
those guys those guys that throw those
big shots like francis because francis
can get a bit wide at times
if he lands knock you off those guys
though you kind of touch them up yes
that's true but
you got to be careful with the other
guys coming too that's what i'm saying
you gotta anticipate this punch by
punching and moving after you punch i'm
saying if you fought a guy like francis
that throws wide like that you inside
all that right inside of you
watching inside the punch but but then
also let's not get twisted
in some weird world and francis lance
it's almost on tyson it's all uh on ty's
interior it's over really it's too hot
you know how many professional guys that
punch
hard tried to hit him and can't do it
right now yo that's what i was going to
say
that's what you say right fury
[Music]
francis because he fought deontay he's
kind of seen a version of you're having
the wrong conversation right now why
because the conversation and the
question right now is mike tyson in his
prime versus fury in his prime who wins
mike
that's the question
mike before you answer this is no
disrespect to me he big
technically wise fury can go he can go
defense his footwork is big to me as far
as technique wise fear is the best we've
ever had oh wow what you doing tyson
hits the hardest route
he might try to lean on you mike trying
to grab you lean on you i don't know
he's rude right now i'm
fury in his prime enticing this crime
who wins telling people the truth
listen
listen
just him being tightly fairy shows my
greatness
tells you my greatness shows his
greatness
hey that's gonna change him after mike
yeah mike that's a great answer i don't
want to know i don't care if he could
beat me or not
he named that his name is tyson his name
is tyson and his dad i don't care he
could beat him over he could beat me i
don't care the name of tyson named after
the greatest fighter ever lived greatest
that was the that was the greatest
that's the one right i love mike tyson
he's one of my best friends in the world
who's this
drake look alike coming got a white
jacket
he didn't like drake didn't he
all right here we go come on
[Laughter]
so listen here's the situation
we're still in the first quarter b
two minutes left we're in sunny
man
the heat index is back out in this world
right now it's never been this hot in
l.a this time of year for hydration
yeah i'm hiking dehydration play a role
a factor in this game
what's that mike what you got something
i don't have some fruit mike got a fruit
plate [ __ ] want to eat [ __ ] yeah
hey
yes we want to eat
come on get some of this everybody
you know what i ain't look like
you know what i'm going for
blueberries he went for blueberries
might help him
mike mikey
thank you
thank you
what the [ __ ] are we doing this morning
we're eating blueberries and chilling
man you want some some great bread i'm
saying better get some grease
get your energy up
let's go let's go two rounds real quick
oh yeah
mike do you like rose fargo i love him
he's the man huh
you got some good cardio mic yeah
are you ready for us man
dc you know i gotta we gotta bring it up
last night's ufc that you worked
robert whitaker izzy
decision yeah robbie whitaker he's gonna
have a tough fight again yeah you had a
tough fight i i watched it this morning
i had you guys
oh yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
breakdown on easy might have you beat
here mike on this shot
it looked like you got a body shot over
the left and he had a right hand about
to drop him again check this out look
look mike it look like you might have
had your beat buddy come on i'll get one
i'll give him another opportunity i'll
give him another opportunity don't mike
it look like he had you i ain't [ __ ]
with him
i ain't this boy crazy man come on hey
mike you have to put him down mike
stop
all right
you poking the beer right now
[Laughter]
oh here you go mike tyson getting makeup
of course he got his own professional
roller
he has lions and tigers
[Applause]
was it first down because we were boxing
go around second down
marsh
talk about greatness this is greatness
oh my god fix your mic that's
understatement fix your mic marshall
they say that when you go they say when
ramsay
they say when ramsay flew outside and
shut down this side oh it's going down
right now
going down right now
oh
[Applause]
mike talk about greatness we're in the
super bowl was first down
he catches the bomb on jaylen ramsay the
best cornerback
in the nfl the last three years not just
this year closest thing we have
greatness it's going to be a war
i'm not going to be easy games that's
what we want i want a high scoring back
and forth we don't want this [ __ ] to be
boring whoa
look at that so they gotta finish listen
this you can't what is that called what
is that calling the ball
that's just a batted pass it's not crazy
that they got von miller
and aaron donald next to each other on
that side
russia got a free hit oh my goodness
knee that boy
that was [ __ ]
yeah let's do that or hit him low but
listen look how hard it is now we're
third and ten again what do you do if
you're in the situation run the ball
you're in the red zone
or do you know you got to take your
points you got to take points after what
you told me after what you told me ten
percent completion so here's something
i'm gonna
so they're going to play the front of
the end zone look at the safeties
they're at the front of the engine you
have the back pedal
whoa
i'm saying it's hard look look it's hard
it's hard to get down there but they
couldn't score now you got to kick three
it's good this is a win for the
cincinnati bengals but it's hard once
you get into tight red when you're
inside this point when you're inside of
the 15 we call this the titan rings
man i you can't go he'll go for
touchdowns
but early you get your man put up points
early's gotta take their points man
that's what we do like like i'm part of
the team
so jaylen ramsey gives up a big play
then he comes down and he stops them
fully redeem himself you gotta listen
next next next next play
y'all got time to look well we got three
you got three right there should come
over how did i know that carpet little
guys
or did you
take it
[Music]
[Laughter]
here's the thing when i played against
darrell reeves i played against bailey
the best of the best
you have literally a half a second
to actually beat them well i used to
tell my quarterbacks if i ran that slant
that same slant against the railroads if
you don't throw it before i even come
out my break it's all the balls going
the other way jayla ramsey almost picked
that ball off when you're going against
elite cornerbacks
man the timing is everything
tell me i don't get inside leverage on
this boy man you don't mind don't get
inside leveraging
joe montana don't get it i'm not wide
receiver but tell them
this guy man look look at that look at
that phone
hey
i didn't know it was you i was looking
at you i'm saying i'm [ __ ] up
[Music]
best one i said you might want me to get
a [ __ ] i might call for a fade wrong
right right marshall
anybody want ginger ale oh i'm saying
man thank you
you're not getting out of here
is that your company
you own a ginger rail company
[Laughter]
second round i thought that robert
whitaker could have won the round
because he had his back third round i
thought izzy won 100 fourth round easy
one
whitaker won round five that was his
best round yep so i thought it was three
to two that's fair but the problem is
the judges some judges gave rob round
three
that's the problem that's because they
don't put any value in the like kids
they got some bad jokes
like you told me this morning like man
did you see that fight as close to
everybody else i was like when i watch
it like i don't see the
the issue at all well when i walked when
i walked in there to interview
i figured izzy had won i just didn't
know how much he had one box
i didn't know if it was gonna be three
to two or four to one but i thought izzy
won the fight yeah i was like there was
no like
so when the crowd reacts in the way that
they did they're booing
i was surprised i was like wow i was
like maybe i was watching a different
fight
but
48 47 48 47 49 46 all for
israel
israel
[Laughter]
goes whitaker he just grabbed his
[ __ ] hand bro
paper i swear to god it was the sickest
i love him israel is out there having
way too much fun he's a superstar
he's just grabbing his bro he grabbed
his hand bro like you beat him on black
paper rock paper scissors no he's like
beat you already like it's over already
got you bro he's having too much fun
in the most long
is he caught two doves last night look
he's being raped
uh i mean come on man
[Music]
has a chance but but on first look
you're like man i'll fight who's beating
is that 185 nobody has
nobody has
all right so it's the best we have to
offer
since we're talking about uh fighting
mike come back
come back
so we're talking about
fighting at the super bowl there's 150
million people tuning in to this super
bowl
i got a question for mike
mike
is this jake paul fight going down yes
or no
oh wow
it was logan paul i think right is it
logan or jake
let me check the next um
i didn't see the last check that they
offered me
what was the last check they offered you
it wasn't enough it wasn't enough not
enough to get mike out there what is
enough mike what's the number like
what's the number if i want to really
if i want to fight you what i got to
come up with
well you don't have to come up with much
you know
i think 25 million with you
[Laughter]
hey mike listen though but there's no
threat what you said is there a threat
is there a threat in that fight with
jake paul
and me yeah there's no threat i don't
think so i mean realistically i don't
think so
yeah i i don't know man i think those
kids those kids can fight a little
better than people want to give him
credit for him well you know logan's a
business man he's just trying to make
the most money
he can actually fight better he can
fight better than they give him all
right here we go
this is important get him get him
oh wow you said i gotta grab his ankle
real quick all right so all right here
we go we're third and long it started
eleven
hey
oh my goodness brandon look at his hair
why do you want to fight this forget him
i don't care about that bro
don't stand with him
come on let's go come on let's go no no
you're here
too let's go
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop
[Laughter]
he's fighting for the championship
in the early spring
and i like seven o'clock
where are you from
hey go get him he is legit hey brandon
he is legit the most scary contender
in the ufc right now that's your next
i've called it for two years now 100 100
he's your next
[Music]
here we go you want to sit down here
yeah please hey hear it
100
this guy's got some confidence in you
here we go guys we're in the red zone
this is talking to mike if you're
talking about it get out
the rams starting to pull away
what are you doing out here
heavy on top i just want to be ready
yeah
bro you're in shape dog how much you
weigh right now how much you weigh right
now
2 15 15. oh he's not even cutting no but
i want to be i want to be ready all the
time
[Laughter]
hey mike please meet this guy man big
pleasure to meet you
thank you brother
i'm short shorts
easy freezing bro what he did what he
did to anthony smith disgrace nuts he's
the real deal he's one of my favorites
and my favorite bro
who do you love fighting for the title
he's going to fight glover attacks you
heavyweight you everybody everywhere
right here
hey glove with something like that
he's been around for a while why don't
you go heavy weights like he's a
champion he jumps jumping and he
idolizes you glover moves like you do
he's a really good grappler black belt
but yeah yuri saw
touchdown
hey i'll tell you who else just i'll
tell you who else just scored our boy
tyler just won 25 000
dollars from money life i'm telling you
man we're not messing around
tyler
from freaking i don't know where he's
from but that boy just won 25 25
000 money lines tyler let me hold
something buddy this ain't a game 20
about money
yeah
money lying it's throwing out the bread
what they say how much money is going to
be giving away 100 000 dollars
25 000 every quarter
you gotta download the moneyline app
right now i'm telling you we just gave
away twenty five thousand dollars
you can wait download the app right now
moneyline app get your money more tag
going thoughts on social
they that wasn't a fake that must have
got blocked because why would you ever
try a fake if you got a line up so far
back now
one hundred percent you don't do that
you can't feel that it had to get
blocked something happened between the
all right the center
like so essentially when they move the
extra point back they've
eliminated the
the the the fake the face right
that is total [ __ ] what's up brother
you're preparing for some for some fight
or it will be or not i've been having a
good time everybody everybody asked me
for that
are we still live right now
[Music]
hey listen
[Music]
they're telling me you're the best one
the best i will be
not i'm not not yet because i'm coming
for that belt yeah i'm that that's just
being with him
i feel like i feel like b i feel like
he's too respectable right now he's too
humble ooh gary yeah
hey when you get out of here look up
yuri and ryzen and the [ __ ] that's the
characteristics of a real assassin quiet
night oh yes brother god is great
brandon
bro
wild boy wild boy yeah but i feel like
he should be calling i feel like you
should be calling mike out right now
indeed
d.c
i'm done
you know
what
hey you know that steak hey you know
that steak that when you like get too
drunk you forget it's on the grill
[ __ ] turn black that's me
i'm done i'm overcooked and done you
done i'm done officially retired man i
retired two years ago almost never
coming back coming back this is crashing
you're done
i want to do this with you
all right bubba watson hey yuri
yeah we love you brother we're rooting
for you i'll
we got
we got bubba wallace nascar legend
and bush coming up right now i'm telling
you i guess oh super bowl guest i'm
guessing
man bubba wallace
yeah there's bubba wallace the legend
kurt busch legend what's up fellas how
you guys doing good luck john
brother get it done rooting for you
man enjoy
go get them bro
don't forget me when i'm ringside
that boy can look more european
yeah bro we got we have the nascar
legends up there right now
[Music]
legends
hey i don't think they can hear us they
can't hear we got you now
what's up fellas how you guys doing man
what up what up we're doing good
how's your super bowl sunday going
uh i didn't have any skin in the game so
i'd say mine's going okay
i got i got a one-man party over here my
wife's getting ready we're going to
valentine's day dinner because we got
daytona rolling up oh that's right
that's a pretty big event that's a
legitimate issue
oh yeah yeah he's a bad snap bad snap
here you go hey hey bubba is not a
bastard hey bubba kurt who's winning
this game we got any uh we got any
favorites here
la's looking strong right now
uh i i was kind of pulling for
cincinnati but
la's la's hot right now no bubba don't
do it i'm taking the bangles man
bubba jim mcmahon thing going on and i
love jim mcmahon and the chicago bears
and the 80s
all right make the pick who's going to
win this game
how you feel how are you cincinnati how
you fellas feeling for the daytona man
everything going well how do you guys
prepare for it
yeah we're feeling good ready to roar
moneyline is all about being alive
and we're ready to roar daytona
so uh it's coming up here and it's uh
it's gonna be a lot of fun brand new
cars
coming over
teamed up on the toyota side so it could
be a lot of fun really cool
i got my i got my new backdrop
oh i love it kurt there you go dog
curt hey kirk can you hear me
kurt can you hear me
we can barely hear you dog
all right y'all can barely hear me kurt
i got i got i got a confession
rowdy is my driver and and bubba those
are my drivers
i think how you feel about that i think
i think we oh there they are the yeah
there's bubba he knows what's up hey
listen fellas don't come by marshall
because the moment you come next to me
try to fight russell you've got to fight
every person that has come over here
hey kurt you making a new move you're
going to a new team talk to us about
that new move brother
i'm digging it uh toyota asked me to
come in as a veteran and build a new
team up and build it alongside puppies
at 22-11 so the race with mk denny
hamlin all these guys uh this is the
perfect scenario for me as a as an
old-school guy as a veteran and it still
has that drive to win oh you saw that
man can
and just partnering up with a new group
of guys it's uh this is what it's all
about cool sponsors as well with monster
energy mcdonald's money lying and uh i
think it's going down baby
i love it i love it it's b shop we got
dc
we got bubba wallace we got kurt busch
we got iron mike tyson here streaming
live this is legendary stuff
unbelievable money lion thank you so
much putting this together this amazing
event talk to me bubba wallace
sure hey
history history
bro
you want talladega talk to us about that
moment
good night
pushing for the witness
continuing to grow
and make big thing happen
so fun to be covered my last part of my
career
most of it had some fun and bringing my
heart
to the sixth grade bridge here
uh awesome
wireless
get your internet right bubba you can't
like you can like take the sponsor's
money but not use them let me ask you
all a question because we got some
legends on the down
right now two legends nascar lines you
guys all right plate racing somebody
tyson mike tyson what's plate racing
beats the [ __ ] out of me
bubba tell her what plate racing is
vomit tell him
an hour feeding bang
right all right great great another
question just like boxing with us
right right another question mike tyson
true or false
kyle
okay
rowdy and kurt
are they related or not
the bush family i ain't saying nothing
about no butch man i just said kyle and
kurt
rowdy what's your nickname uh kurt
i i don't know i've been a bunch of
different names
the boss we gonna call you the boss yeah
they're all family members they are yes
ding ding ding yes yes yes great job
great job they're freaking legendary and
they're from vegas
their father is phenomenal their father
helped him
yep
vegas in the house
hey kurt bubba we love you guys come on
good luck tomorrow man
for you
stay safe man and keep crushing and both
you guys thanks for coming on fellas
appreciate that thank you
later you got it guys hey anybody that's
tuned in there's money up for grabs from
daytona so you got to register the money
line raising
there you go
they're giving money away during nascar
money money line all over the world
we're in the red zone again guys
we uh uh iron mike has a a lot of money
on the line for the cincinnati bengals
he needs to be a good driver okay six
second and six now it's third and short
if i'm mike tyson we want a touchdown
here mike a lot of money
to me we're in two down territory
already yes let me tell you why
if i'm in this situation right now
second quarter seven minutes to go
i run the ball on third down and then i
see what position i'm in and i'm and
i'll give myself a run pass option we
call those rpos on fourth down hey hey
brandon let me ask you this why is aaron
donald so good what's the deal aaron dar
step first off his mindset mike will
enjoy this this dude
is next level when it comes to mindset
he's a monster out there he's trying to
oh here we go here we go first down go
go another one
aaron donald is next level when it comes
to mindset eighty percent of the game
eighty percent of sport is in your mind
it's mental twenty percent is physical
so the physical he's next level we're
talking about a dude plays deep into the
line but he moves and runs and he's
built like a linebacker he's jacked
jack
he's jacked but it all starts with his
mindset i saw aaron donald curse out a
guy on the field
his own teammate i'm playing against
aaron donald when i'm playing for the
saints and our offensive line is
crushing
i'm playing for the seattle seahawks
they're crushing the la rims what are
they doing
and and aaron daughter looks as his
defensive lineman next to him and says
if you play like this if you let them
treat you like this your ass cannot be
on this field with me oh wow that's what
he said to his own team
his mindset is next level
yeah marshall how was he playing for the
saints how is playing the song
how is it living in like playing in this
like a city like that that's not one of
my los angeles one of my greatest
football experiences ever really oh my
god
oh chick-fil-a let's get this money
money
let's get this money mike shadowbox
shadowbox let's get this money mike he
said it oh my god i did it mike wins
this mike has a thousand psychedelic
trucks
there's a lot of money there's no
mushrooms around here the saints was
next level man one of my greatest
mushrooms in my car because it's not a
massive city
no but you have to do that it's
ridiculous you know how to party hey
they kind of suck now though
no they'll be yeah we can't we can fight
but
dennis allen you know he was the
defensive coordinator so he's been
around
hopefully dennis allen is next level
yeah he's a great coach so hopefully
who's the starter now for you guys
well last year
go baby uh it was james's wednesday this
morning and they were all day every day
if the cincinnati bengals wins oh my god
what is mike taking home
trevor simeon oh my goodness
trevor simming he has everything
physically but that's necessary
it's not always the guys with the the
that's most gifted physically listen the
mentor is everything at that level
i was taught this about the mental and
bodybuilding especially after you walk
away from the game it's everything you
know it i was taught this
your body's only purpose to carry your
brain
look at that mike's smart man mike god
damn it mike turns strong
if i'm dropping no it's like that i'll
lick that frog right you're a
philosopher like who do you study what
are you like where are you getting this
stuff from bro no you spent games
on every show every podcast that you're
on
every time there's a camera in front of
you a mic in front of you you spit game
who are you studying bro i'm not nobody
everything i do
there's somebody's quotes but it's from
my experience in life i don't see nobody
quoting really some guys listen there's
some guys that never
control a baton of men an army and their
quotes are more legendary than god that
actually fought on the field
he's like a bruce lee guy bruce lee
never gotten any [ __ ] he never fought
anybody but he fired so many fighters he
did can you believe that yeah and so
that
that's good too because that's in that's
um that's contributing to fighting yeah
so you got just as good as fighting yeah
yeah i just watched i just watch his uh
his movies
oh like the last dragon
yeah he was the man to me to me the
greatest athlete no
is bruce lee
listen listen it's my time it's my time
like this that's my time oh no that's my
[ __ ] guy
who do you have you can't see that bruce
lee
michael jordan
like that hold on go ahead please tell
me
if you want to go off statistically
who's the best athlete of all time
uh wayne gretzky
the most dominant figure [ __ ] words
that
williams
that's a better athlete
let me tell you something stop stop
saying he's my favorite so he's not my
friend
dude hold up the 150th 150th ranked dude
would beat the [ __ ] out of sharing or
venus destroy it yeah destroy it no not
150. no you can't though no those are
facts no
150 that's not true
what is wrong with y'all
he might be no
you believe in [ __ ]
[Music]
the greatest athlete be careful now the
dude that like wins the olympics in the
uh decathlon that bruce jenner used to
win yeah
that's the dude ally
caitlyn
when he was bruce jenner talked to
colleagues
how many people compete in that they do
ten events brandon if he decided to do
it would win that event no bro you tell
me he's not better off
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
nobody who knows doesn't matter but that
person is still the best athlete in the
world
that person is doing it here we go here
you are breaking my heart because that
person could go play football ten people
thinking
come on let's look at the [ __ ] game
that person from the olympics
[Music]
he was injured before he dropped the
ball yeah
[Music]
the commercials used to be a big deal
are they still a thing now is that a big
deal anymore i don't know i know pete
davidson is doing a lot of stuff for it
there's supposed to be some fire
commercials but
yeah
this cyborg got all kind of makeup on my
shirt
bro why did you tell me i had that all
over my shirt before he pulls this [ __ ]
man all right fellas remember moneyline
is giving out 25k a quarter that's a
hundred grand over the course of super
bowl all you gotta do is download the
moneyline app right now get your money
roar tag going follow us on social and
comment with your money war tag right
now 25k we've already given out 25k the
next winner is coming up stay tuned make
money watch the stream with us it's that
easy moneyline download the app right
now
damn bro you boys broke my heart with
that best athlete combo i don't want to
really i don't want to rehash it
you said some crazy [ __ ] man well you
said the craziest [ __ ] bruce lee the
best [ __ ] yeah i might believe that i'm
in spite's [ __ ]
you might be the best philosopher
you might be the best mind well see
that's the everybody's definition of the
athlete is different so you gotta show
so then jordan peterson's a great app
you gotta show on iron mafia how many of
you this is your deal
i can't you're
[Laughter]
she's the best female athlete of all
time no that's the problem is a female
she's the best if
serena williams the best athlete if you
put her mindset in anybody you have
michael jordan
she's the greatest so we can't it's hard
for gender if we're going by athlete
based on mindset it's michael jordan
serena williams
watch you pull up
oh damn yeah he blew that knee up
his hair looks dope though that's not
good
don't look good at all
[Applause]
out of all the times to do it out of all
the freaking time to do it
acl mcl
there's this one 39 no they're going to
super cup first don't go for it cooper
county buy one eastern
[Applause]
they're not gonna do anything
mike what was your bet mike
he got straight up you got the bingos
right straight up
i like that bit
you like how the game is going right now
for your bingo i didn't like
[Music]
mike we talking 50 g's on this game what
are we talking about
i was gonna bet something in that
quality but they understand about five
oh okay
mike tyson back five five they don't
wanna you pay your guy to roll blondes
that today dog
hey mark
uh whiskey yeah
i should've brought my whiskey man
all you boys are gonna text during the
stream all right
after talking all that trash about best
athletes now you jump on your phone
because he embarrassed you boys are wild
he's embarrassed
both people
i'm not wrong
i really believe
[Music]
get out come on stafford
yeah
that's a veteran move that's a veteran
move
mike say hi to v hey v how you doing
buddy
i'm doing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is sick
hey and b marshall do you know did that
hedrick hedrickson the the captain for
bengals was he on ohio state when the
bozo was on
are they the same class i think so but
i really don't know i played with him my
last year oh he's a snug
he just stopped yeah he was the real
deal
he didn't even dress up in 2018 he was
on the bench damn that's right that
shows you what kind of monsters in the
nfl bro he was sitting on the sideline
he wasn't addressing him sitting there
right next to him
yeah i had such high hopes
i swear to god
i just i just had lunch with coach i was
like
[Music]
here we go third and 14. starting for
10.
[Music]
continues to get richer that's exactly
what you said
yeah
the rich continues my boy staffers
what does mike know about football what
does he know that i don't know team
gritty
team gritty how does he pick the
cincinnati's feeling good he's rolling
another blunt
look lol
[Music]
that's why they don't finish something
thanks brother she's got a limited
edition
[Music]
mike you think you have 50 today
mike you live in l.a vegas newport
i lived in vegas i moved out here for my
daughter to play tennis in newport beach
now we're moving to boca raton for my
daughter to play tennis let's go that's
where i live yeah that's where we going
you were the floor i'm a trainer huh
come to my facility
yeah for my daughter she wants to be a
tennis player wins
that's what i want to be a golfer that's
where coco lives and yeah so mike what
about your podcast studio and all that
[ __ ] you got to go down there now you
all got to move huh yeah oh they're all
going are you coming down
um the end of
this month and next month my channel
save money on that we got aaron mike
coming to south florida baby let's go i
bet the santa's man
i live 20 minutes away yeah
yeah
[Music]
yeah we do all that
of course
you got to
what are you doing man come here rocco
rocco mike he looks just like you man
that's my boy
and he wants to be a golfer he is a
golfer
what
what's up
great what
someone told me to tell you is ducky
cash not drake
i don't know
lucky has
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i don't know son we got we got
the we got
tiger woods 2.0 right here say hi say hi
to the people come here
come here tell us about your game we got
the microphone where's the microphones
come over here right here in between me
and dc because we don't want your dad to
jump in this conversation right now come
here
give him again boom boom
all right hello so we got yongin right
here youngin tell us about your game
what's up brother um it's going pretty
good i'll start my tournament in march
12th you think you can beat me yeah
oh you see you got your dad
oh
[Music]
you know what time it
is man y'all gotta throw a little cup
no [ __ ] we even fighting we're going
everybody gotta see me come on
championship first time
punch that [ __ ] punch him bro big hand
him cheers
[Laughter]
biggest
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no
he's about to get over here
you're probably about to get this boy
here we go
this is the best wide receiver in the
game three years from now give us your
prediction
who's going to win the game talk to us
man i got lorraine i got i got the rams
going
your your idol odell just went down
you know what i'm saying the bengals
gonna beat your [ __ ] ass man
ain't gonna lie to you you know
you gotta watch
look at this [ __ ] look what's happening
man this is dirty mike what's going on
you're already like just looking at me
baby you talking to the mic
we locked the episode
you got [ __ ] i've been talking young
[ __ ] [ __ ] when we gonna see the jets in
the super bowl
man y'all just tune in for so many
loading so that's right this dude right
here next level i'm already miked up
gold feet he ready you're going to lead
the lead to the jets to the super bowl
manifestation we're putting it in the
work you're grinding hard you keep going
first you're fighting against me i'm not
really too much in the prediction it's
about what we're about to do
enough said now we go back to the
broadcast we got jennifer lopez emmitt
smith
watching live
and this is my team right here jets baby
jets
all right here we go guys hey what we
got to understand is this is elijah
moore
elijah moore tell these people
what round you went last year you
sitting there in new york with with zach
wilson and tell these people what y'all
learned
i mean i went i went second round
really went first in my head you know i
really went number one really went top
ten
man we just about to be legendary he's
got two in there and that's it so so
elijah
we're sitting here watching the super
bowl your idol now i wouldn't say your
idol guy that you study and look up to
odell you train odell beckham jr
goldfeet global down here in south
florida how did it feel seeing odell go
down in the biggest moment of his
playing career
yeah we always gonna prevail though you
know we pray pray we prayers up so we
good everything's great man yeah we was
on the way here so we didn't see exactly
i'm getting text messages
we'll get a little update but you know
we're gonna let god handle the rest
that's awesome we got gold feet global
make sure you go get the merch and
support we got elijah moore next level
thank you how you feeling all right
[Music]
man bless us for all of us man enjoy
today enjoy your families enjoy the ones
around you tonight
you know what i mean uh we don't have
tomorrow
so for everybody man just stay blessed
and let's go rams let's go bengals
you know what i mean
the way you win money you download the
moneyline app
and you can win twenty five thousand
dollars a hundred thousand dollars okay
our boy lakey coney i think that's a
real nightmare lakey coney just won 25
grand
watching the super bowl watching this
stream moneyline yeah lakey enjoy the
money man
that i would take your money and bet on
the rams
bro i just want to get back to you
download the money line app right now on
that field on that atmosphere it's
really good to watch and don't wait too
because the way you win the 25k we're
giving away 25k in the third quarter
fourth quarter it's a hundred thousand
dollars total
download the moneyline app right now get
your money roar tag going follow us on
social and comment with your money more
tag download the moneyline app 25k got
nothing to
they let them walk around like this
yeah yeah yeah nobody robbed you here
hey so you know he played for the jets
mike
picture picture picture
we got a camera
all right we got bobby molly right
camera picture
photos
you don't smoke man you want to take it
for him
rams
here we go
we got second to ten this is a big down
get him get him
here we go super cub they've actually
done a pretty good job
bro we make super cute touchdowns
this is the receiver dude we're talking
about a receiver watching
yes but i'm old i'm retired he's active
he's the next one up what makes cooper
cub special man probably really just his
man's patience he looks like he's real
real pacing he understands his own he
understands the pictures
means a smart smart player you see the
way he talks he weight interviews man he
just knows what he's doing no he knows
football
i love it last question for you before
we let you enjoy your your super bowl
watch party here with with money lion uh
how much does your chain cost because
we're his money line is presenting
sponsor all right and we're talking
about money and financial literacy how
much is this this charm man i love peace
man
[Laughter]
love
respect
respect
me thank you
[Applause]
it's almost half time
oh [ __ ] going down it's almost going
down and for the viewers out there on
half time we're going to take a little
break you guys enjoy the halftime show
and remember download the moneyline app
in the third quarter fourth quarter
giving away 25k all you gotta do is
download the app moneyline app get your
money roar tag going follow us on social
and comment with your money roar tag 25k
third quarter fourth quarter we've got
two guys winning the first in the second
quarter it's too easy man to make money
[Music]
that's it man we're about to go to
halftime enjoy the halftime show we're
going to get a break we're going to fuel
up on food and shrooms and
chronic and some chronic with mike enjoy
the halftime show we will be back for
the third quarter download the moneyline
app make some money we'll see you in the
third quarter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh
what's up everybody thank you guys for
tuning in here we are at the money line
matt the lion's den with my money line
baby brandon marshall daniel cormier
money lion
oh 20 now 21 is it 21 no 17 i'm sorry
i'm [ __ ] up in math
that's the problem
yo what up what up what up what up here
we go
and look who wins look who wins yeah but
push off uh
and the question was why is this number
still even available it's not out there
before the season outside
i need that
no i don't want to talk to nobody
for this season
we'll never see a reason oh never retire
but this is a great way to go out and i
love that refresh
i need a bottle of whatever brand of
marshmallows
financial freedom financial help
you need to continue to teach us retired
guys and these active guys what to do
with that
second half it's vital tell me how to
think you guys got a hole right here
they gotta hold them probably five
hundred thousand these guys are moving
mike i want a high scoring game though i
just want to entertain people
on
bowl tv yeah
i want to straight up shoot talk about
like for you coming into the league how
was it making mistakes financially like
how did you learn somebody taught you or
you had to learn on your own
there you go yeah so what i did was yes
you guys
like the financial dictionary
and i got these uh these note cards and
on these note cards i wrote down all the
terms
you know what i mean i wrote down even
if it's a spring all these things
and i signed a 50 million dollar deal
but before i would invest my money
i would on every away trip when we're on
a plane to go into the new the new
england patriots or the jets i would
actually take out all these notes note
cards about 50 note cards
all right
so i would study i would study these
note cards before i would invest i had
50 million sitting in the bank before i
would even invest because i wanted to
understand 50 million in the bank
basically that's crazy
a lot 50 million dollar deal and i
didn't start investing until i
understood what all these terms meant
what is liquidity what is like something
simple is that well i want to know the
fundamentals before i sit at the table
with these people to say i'm about to
invest your money and now let's go joe
22
interest are returned every single year
so my money's making money
nah that's that's so important that's so
important man so many people go broke
because they don't understand what you
just said 100 i mean you know we think
about uh money line that's why it's
important like where is the right
platform for us to go and partner with
to actually help entrepreneurs and
startups or just people who have what
they have to extend it you know i know
from my life expectancy standpoint that
my money is going to last my children's
children if i stick to the game plan
that we implemented 10 years ago
that's key i love what you're doing i am
athlete like you really are transcending
the game and becoming a media mogul too
yeah i mean that's the opportunity bro
like
one time raises all ships you know to me
i am at this incubator and accelerated
for talent around athens
that's point blank period bro you know
it would be selfish of me now if i only
focus on myself and my platform can we
bring this right here
that's the question
they're in the franchise
nobody's really done that before in the
podcast space that's right i am at the
la i am at the houston bumby kendrick
perkins la you got swaggy p
keenan beasley and it's the same thing
it's rocky room talking about him first
conversation first time
[Music]
don't wrap them anymore though but they
never played oh joe burrow joe burrow
got that swagger up
ain't no stopping
ain't nothing ain't nothin
oh
skirmish ref we're just gonna
[Music]
mike watch cincinnati
watch cincinnati i see aaron donald
trying to put somebody in there
i like two games and the colors too like
the colors black and orange
and that's why
[Music]
we got playing football what would you
be what anybody touch the mouth
full back i would want to be whatever
lawrence taylor was
like
yeah
yeah no no no no you wanted to be lt if
i would play football i wouldn't want to
be him yeah
[Music]
there was a husband and wife that was
split up husband was sitting in first
class white position and i don't know
what you guys coach
going for three lt
his wife just said you know what taking
my seat because i said go over your
husband take my seat i'll go sit in
coach
legendary
he's going for he's going for it first
class humility bro great athlete too
he's going for it a great athlete could
perform when he's hurt
so so we gotta earn your leisure here
what's up brother ladies and gentlemen
so so these dudes they talk about
that's getting money right now what
should they do with it how should they
be thinking how should they be
approaching it because we gotta earn
your leisure here well first the thing
you should know
i don't care
what kind of family you come from what
status you are
there's the art to manage your money i
grew up you know there's no more of
these robber barons because they got 19
1912
taxes came and they wiped all those guys
out so brother
i like the excitement of it yeah yeah i
like the risk of it
it tests your humanity it's like sports
and this is this book yeah
was like 87. so doug williams won and i
was like that's my team yep and i i've
been loyal since
three guys
91 is the last time this this company
this thought it started with a thought
in the dream in 2013
and now you know this is a public
trading company
you know like what i what i appreciate
about moneyline is the education because
i feel like a lot of us
and i'm talking about black white male
female
we don't know
because the one percent is really what
controls
so i appreciate because the education
component from not only money line but
also
yeah you know it's needed you know
coming from where we come from we're not
taught that just make mistakes because
you don't know what to do education
comes from more than just going to
school but that's what we do in life we
don't we get off the fence and we make
mistakes and we learn from our mistakes
in order to become a master you first
have to be a fool
you know nothing happens overnight
say that again be in order to become a
master you got to first move forward yes
fully even want to accomplish that
hold on it's 33
[Music]
if you try to block it with one man
there's no chance look at aaron donald
going against the right guard we know
that this is the weakest link on the
offensive line mine it's one on one look
what he's doing too two of them
literally no there's no two of them it's
one
he got two guys the one guy grabbed two
guys no that's the problem mike how you
going every play put two people on aaron
donald that's like you bro
this dude from pittsburgh pennsylvania
penn hills the the poorest town they're
gonna do it the bangor's gonna do this
[ __ ] again
except twenty twenty mango's doing this
[ __ ] again get him over hey who that who
they who they
are the game is over no let's go home
mike shut down the streams no shut down
the stream no don't shut it down here
stay right here mike don't take this out
of your house please there you go
it's over my life is taking home fifty
to a hundred thousand dollars on all his
best this fight's far from over big
it's
ten
mike
i did everything you told me to do right
now
i bet the way you told me to bet right
right respect he listened to me
he listened to me it's over
this is not over
hey remember fam we're giving another
25k away with money lying coming up very
soon third quarter giving away 25.
fourth quarter giving away 25. that's
50k man 50k we gave away 50k last half
we're doing again this half
right now downloading these beautiful
black people uh app right now and you
got a chance to win 25k
beautiful black people amazing right
yeah
hey linda
have you had her on the show no i meant
this though before
i'll be here
yeah man god bless you
y'all are you out of here you know i
gotta be tired
you love brother
hey hey come here you don't have my
number
you do nothing
[Music]
you're a liar
[Music]
wow oh my god
okay
[Music]
they're doing tattoos
they're tap people in the back there you
know okay well you can just freak
tattoos back
yeah are we still live right now we're
still alive all right we're live right
now anybody that's here right now we're
giving free tattoos in the back this is
crazy
they're not they're not watching the
stream in the house
yeah
we must have that second hand i don't
think they watched it
i wish i had those right i'm on this
carnivore diet right
now
right yeah that's what you told me i'm
starting today let's start this
carnivore diet
if you ain't forming it don't eat it
you know it's in vegetables yeah which
you tell me what's in vegetables
there's some vegetables that are
poisonous that'll kill you
meat is
a
basic consumption of meat alone is bad
every day in moderation meat
fish
um veg everything every day in
moderation what's your diet besides uh
psychedelics and weed what's your diet
what you eating any kind of meat i eat i
eat like a bison
uh
a gold or
an elk or something like that
yeah
it's all red meat might know what he's
talking about it's all right dude right
here bro
mike eight i didn't think i think it's
unrealistic not to eat meat that's my
pleasure
all right let's go ladies and gents now
cause you got a lot of money on the line
well 15 to 20. you know that's fine the
los angeles rams are trailing by seven
and if you know how to count then you
know
seven and the third are down by seven in
the third it's the third quarter okay
10 minutes left in the game
this is a crucial drive [ __ ]
bang bang you're going to put a lot of
pressure on 25k we got only got five
kids
is it did you download more might you
put more on it i told him he said he's
going to pay for put five dollars don't
put down twenty five thousand i'm fine
mike you don't need more than that you
got way too much money if you make
twenty five fifty a hundred thousand it
doesn't matter like you better put the
five down be happy
what you're going
hold on dc
what is this 38 is right third longboard
we go for it
we go for it right that's the middle
three by two it's not long enough to do
the draw or the screen this one we
actually break up convert
cooper cup
back yeah
mike
that is classic back shoulder what
happens is that back shoulder running
back wide receiver runs the go route
okay if the db is over top and i can't
get you to catch it over my shoulder
throw it back shoulder watch watch watch
marshall this is a pen plate cooper cup
is trying to get the pick he's trying to
get them safety to take him
matthew stafford read it beautifully
through the back shoulder if he boss 55
or too [ __ ] slow how how how much how
do they have to change their game plan
now that odell beckham's out because
cooper they can double cooper cup
remember
but they already have the chemistry and
continuity
had to figure out how to implement it so
they're fine they're fine oh work
thank god when did this
[Music]
that always happened allegedly boomer
osiris in front of cincinnati bengals
ironically the cincinnati bengals are in
the super bowl was the first team to
implement the back shoulder no no sorry
phil sims in the new york giants way
back this back then bro didn't seem like
they were doing it that much on the back
shoulder
yes the commentators just weren't
noticing because bill parcells was the
head coach and bill barcelona
if my six three six four six five wide
receiver is open i mean if he's covered
he's open the store to him and that's
where the back shoulder was discovered
he's throwing the ball good too
good at that oh
[Applause]
that's my sweat rack he's just going out
oh it was dropping
oh go
he was hurt he's been hurt yeah
oh they better watch out still no odell
still no el dale tyson i think he's done
he's calling you tyson tell me whatever
he likes
what does your wife and your kids call
you
[ __ ] oh so many names i can't tell
you the name
so mr mike tyson
oh there's no odell beckham jr
this is devastating where is he at right
so
hopefully it's not an acl or mcl type
and
cert
see him recover quickly but there's no
jose beckham jr right now in the biggest
moment of his career you just said
they're gonna be fine
they'll be fine
100
but i'm thinking i'm speaking to the
player
we've played or fought
so we understand we're in a position we
know that
when you see most broadcasts these guys
covering the sport they can't relate
so odell can you relate to o'dell in
this moment yeah i think it's the
biggest moment of his career and he's
not he's no more worse he's the worst
because you understand the spot oh wow
it's always not your second and or third
you still have a chance to put any money
on this game
put everything on the cincinnati bengals
guy
okay i play with these guys look at that
this game is all over
boom
think about what they did to the
cincinnati bengals last year patrick
last week patrick mahomes
the best quarterback in the business you
got smoking joe burrow on the sidelines
saying
he's calm now he's caught up dc
he's calm he's no longer nervous he's
got the receipt
i mean
this guy get down
hey too much pressure too much pressure
too much pressure mike when you start
doing
reverse passes it's over
come on cooper cup played quarterback in
high school yeah you got to hit that
cooper cup
his wife he knows it see football
players know the moment this is a big
moment we needed that first down
it's kind of like how you was earlier i
didn't get 16 it was like how you was
earlier
when earlier when i was fighting you and
i hit you with the hook and he was like
ah like okay this football player he
might have a little too much
sword
did you have uh
illusion bro
mike what's up man you know you can't do
me
no i can't i
okay whenever they tell me we're good
right now they're sliding under here
we're good
awesome 100 yeah introduce yourself man
yeah my name is tejas i'm a tick tocker
a couple drinks in right now and have a
fun a couple fun questions for you guys
yeah just turn trump
all right
all right
in the [ __ ]
marsh you ain't got your dog broken
[ __ ] knife
all right
who the hell
me
but i got a couple fun questions for you
all okay about the super bowl all right
it's a competition between you all okay
all right
the first question is
how many pounds of potato chips are
going to be eaten today
in the nation how many pounds of potato
chips are going to be 8000
[ __ ] no
i know i got points
millions 1 billion dc says a million
what about you 10 000. 10 000 pounds
how many times you got to convert it oh
ten thousand tons yeah that's times two
thousand oh see
you're a money lion
did they pay you for that what what is
that what is it what's the number
11.2 million pounds of potato chips
what's that divided by 2 000. i don't
know
call them money like guys
11 million divided by 2 000 what do we
got
oh that's not enough that's it all right
second question
how many chicken wings are eaten today
chicken wings what do you got how the
[ __ ] i know
i'm with tyson on this i'm sorry about
that [ __ ]
150 million
people's
viewing live the super bowl i'll say one
two chicken wings the number one food
yeah
each person averages five chicken wings
that's it
twenty are going to eat okay so this is
500 million let's do 50 million times
five fifty minutes absolutely
what is the number 250 250 that's the
number 1.4 billion chicken wings are
eaten today
[Applause]
you're a business major this is what i
do at school i'm not a business major
i'm a football manager
i just do business
hey i'm the great case study
all right at the final
[ __ ] right here how much money
is los angeles making today
because of the super bowl they're losing
right now i don't know let me tell you
why they're like no not the city not the
city though
let me tell you why
oh cause the new
super bowl their home team
so you got to think about travel knowing
the airlines
the hotels
so
when
six weeks ago
everything was times five
when the rams won the nfc
north the nfc okay conference
everything was cut in half by cut cut by
half i chose to make that because
everybody's here already yeah the people
are here you don't have to travel that's
right i want singles fans here one and a
half billion dollars how much
billion yes
billion billion billion i'll say two
billion billion you said two billion
nine hundred and six money how much is
the city of los angeles making because
of a super bowl i don't
[Laughter]
you're the closest 500 million
this freaking guy is the business mind
oh yeah and you know what i am
i'm the freaking head of the freaking
army
all right like i'm gonna go get it let's
go
you just turned 21 uh three months ago
but i'm still trying drinks you got a
recommendation for me i don't know too
much oh whiskey just 18. you can't go
wrong sweet whiskey no proper 12 how
dare you hey
tiger thick whiskey is he here don't
listen
that's his partner that's his partner i
own it
tiger thing is it a tequila no it's an
american whistle everybody watching
right now tiger thing
go we're going to find it what can we
find is japanese it'll be online i'll
blast out we have distribution all over
the nation so listen you know what's the
one thing you got to understand let me
teach you you're 21 right 21. when mike
tyson
or b or dc might rise their company
we need the support
because mike tyson is also employing
300 400 people
and those 300 400 people are making
their communities better so we talk when
we talk about generational wealth
we got to support i mean what does that
even look like right right only he would
not like 100 million look like mike yeah
it doesn't fill this building up
let them fill this room up no no a
couple brief comments
for mike 100 100 buildings doesn't fill
this room really 100 million 100 million
wow
that's crazy he's only with that
touchdown mike the only one that doesn't
have 100
that's my my give me a million right now
mike
what's holding you back from giving me a
million what i got to do to get a
million from mike tyson
like eating that fruit
he's
i can't do
is
one more [ __ ]
oh you can see him here right yeah
[Music]
when is this [ __ ] over
nice to meet
meet you all right thank you doctor bro
thank you bro that young man came in
here and got bobby slain bobby marshall
then forced to smoke weed with my
awesome bag y'all some bullies man
shut the [ __ ] up okay
mike why are you talking to them
you know
mike why you talking like that bro
[Laughter]
[ __ ] smoke this
just give me five yards staffer that's
it bam he gave me five yeah that's okay
so now it's starting manageable dc
that means we go for it
i mean i'm gonna go for it like i'm
talking about trying to get it we're not
giving the draw okay we're not doing
like we gotta explain what's up cause
you said we still but we're not
you got your money that's funny i just
want to still break them
you want to break them yeah and make
this fine
why did you pick the cincinnati bengals
i'm sweating laughing at this guy they
had a history of coming back from behind
so i reached my money on somebody like
that why because i know they wanted real
bad to desire to win
they were down the last three weeks to
make it to the super bowl they overcame
all right we got three about less than
three minutes left don't forget we're
giving away 25k in this third quarter
we've already given away fifty thousand
dollars 25 third quarter 25k in the
fourth quarter that guy did all you
gotta do is download the moneyline app
right now man it's super easy that's how
you win 25k like i did download the
moneyline app mike's gonna lose 5k like
i did get your money roar tag going
follow us on social and comment your
money war tag
25k get away 50k let's go like i did
hey for anybody for anybody
[Music]
tell us who you want to come sit next to
who's going to get punk by mike tyson
send somebody over here moneyline for
mike to talk to you who's getting [ __ ]
up
mike why the hell is your feet so big
oh damn we got this
get my foot [ __ ]
is
why you so tight huh why you so tight no
need for me to be tired
why didn't he want my foot
i can't take this [ __ ] man like where
size is 15. don't hit me mike don't hit
me with a hook dog
yo
you wearing bigger size than me
for easily 13.64
these
[Laughter]
me
[Laughter]
oh my god are you good you good mike i'm
horrible oh you're horrible you little
what you doing
are you like are you are you into
foreplay
are you
one yeah are you in the fourth place he
said are you getting
that's what we talking about like you
got rear size 14 and you five two you
wanna see my dick
you keep being phallic with my foot
when you smoke that tyson everybody take
that taxi
[Music]
he might hit me with a hook you better
leave that man alone though
i'm sweating
bro y'all gotta leave michael on dogs
you want to scoot through the middle
they wants to scoot down they want to
scream
look you keep messing with it man
mike is coming back we're good and and
it might come back again with the
[ __ ] i'm gonna knock mike's ass out
[Laughter]
i'm trying to do the [ __ ] show man
mike this is big it's third down it's
starting again hold this watch it's a
big moment champ
mike you got a lot of money on the line
y'all
the cincinnati bengals is up but at any
moment this game can flip you have von
miller this is the problem what he's
doing to this right tackle that's called
a t-e
that's a t-e stunt
the defensive end comes out
[Applause]
get the ball out quick oh that ain't
[ __ ] that's the player yeah
that's all he needed right there dude
you hear mike mike talking about like my
talking about that's all we needed right
there
why are you [ __ ]
hey
mike tyson
toad
there we go
i wish mike tyson goes
big moment in the game right here
hey mike
whenever you do that frog stuff how long
does it last huh
how long does it like last the
psychedelic 20 minutes
[Applause]
but you're going to feel like a 2 000
hours
you're going to feel like 2 000 years
hey mike mike mike is it a drop or
you're licking the frog no you drop
smoking oh smoke
but like it only lasts 40 minutes
i'm going to take you right to god
really but it makes you kind of like go
like different
it helps you rise to your highest
potential
yeah look at mike d.c try it i was a
junkie i was under the junkyard on
cocaine i was like oh dinos i almost
died i just told
look at me
this is my party
bro
successful business everything
huh everything changed
y'all guys know you guys read about me i
mean i was [ __ ] up i was dying now i
don't even i can't even believe this
[ __ ] i'm just
[ __ ] paying me to have a
party my kids
[Music]
that's crazy
yeah cincinnati's winning though they
already they're about to be losing
though i i bet you ran score this big
drive right here it's also the only time
they got the game a lot of people coming
a lot of people coming into this game
we're giving away 25k kids let's go
download the app moneyline
and you know what we just gave away 25k
so you missed out
don't be sad just giving away 25k in the
fourth quarter
tiffany duke just won twenty five
thousand dollars with money life hey
people really looking at this [ __ ]
right
unless you're overly rich you should be
downloading this app people really look
good you should be trying to win extra
money
there mike
mike's saying we're really watching this
[ __ ] right now
we got thousands of people watching
right now
yes
of course you're mike tyson this is
awesome [ __ ] that's what he sees
four quarters mike's smoking another
blunt everybody mike it's the fourth
quarter
hey it's the championship rounds right
now we live right now
are we live when that kid was over here
hey
everybody watching right now
this is the championship round
the fourth quarter you're gonna see 53
guys on the sideline holding up the
floor and what that means and what that
symbolizes is that
this
is where champions
okay
where's my character right there he came
back mike it's my channel
look
i appreciate it can i
tell our house
can i be the exclusive sponsor of code
here
my name is hey
you gotta do business with mike mike
real now
what you looking for how much you
looking for that
is
oh bro
this young man
bro you know you're rushing for a
fraternity
you're high enough so that's pretty high
well inhale yeah
starts lighting up hey that's good
that's something strong mike's not broke
it really is
hey
young man have you smoked weed before
yeah okay
you smoke weed every day
no okay it's good we're gonna be higher
what the [ __ ] is this liquor i i drink
tequila you smoke weed
how much you can't get i deal with that
you girl with that yeah you got to
educate me though and i might [ __ ]
cause no no no mike i do believe from
anxiety depression standpoint
and stress management
psychedelics and marijuana i can learn
from it and i can embrace it differently
for real so like that's real and that's
why i love listening to you
in hot boxing because you're educating
people
i'm just getting high [ __ ]
my mother win that money though
mike what are you going to do with the
money when you when the cincinnati [ __ ]
excuse me what are you doing with the
earnings
from your
your your bet is
what are you doing with that money i'm
going to disneyland [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i love you i'll get out of here
yeah get out before it might get you
down that pool you stay on the straight
narrow young man no more drugs hey man
stay away from people like this group
stay away from people like this group
yeah you're too young
you'll be good
here we go
third and seven
empty formation they went for it all
they weren't that's a big box phase
that's that's that's jefferson his
father
was a legend at the university of
central florida and then also with the
detroit lions he's a wide receiver coach
right now in the nfl oh wow this dude is
next level but it's in the bloodline
[ __ ] in the deadline 100
but if that's odell jr he comes down
with this now we're missing odell
beckham the reality is eli apple is
terrible
um
eli apple's hanging off okay you know he
is dog he ain't playing with the saints
you know he like halfway really [ __ ]
you know football
but you know eli airplane regarding [ __ ]
i'm going to say facts and i'm going to
move on
[Laughter]
hey that's dc one of the greatest
fighters of all time we're talking about
ufc double
double champs this dude knows football
he's talking about eli apple and why
this guy
was able to go from the saints and not a
cincinnati bengals and still give up
planes
he's still giving up plays
second down oh my god mike what's going
to happen what's the outcome man we got
13 minutes left
we have a lot of time we got a lot of
time to talk to the people what's
happening what's wrong what's going to
be the outcome hey listen right now they
have guts out there fighting with one
another not really any technique just
becoming successful
we're going to hope um
in the
next third down will get better i think
that makes brother from
michigan as a graduate
again
[Laughter]
remember hold up fellas it's the fourth
quarter we got another 25 000 to give
out 25k
is going out download the money live
get your money roar tag going follow us
on social comment using the money uh
roar tag do all that download oh my man
it's your last chance to win 25k we've
given out 75 thousand dollars during
this entire freaking streaming whatever
you want to call it look we're gonna we
are in a minute obj's in the street
clothes oh man
it's bad
he looked like he was tearing up
oh he's a huge asset to the team yeah he
is yeah he is
it's just odd seeing the bengals in the
super bowl
i mean
was the last time they played the super
bowl
the band played the 49ers was like icky
woods
that's bad and he had his dance remember
the icky man you know what he danced him
and his mother had a commercial
you remember the icky do the icky
shuffle [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not a good leader okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
here's the deal though
oh no that's not good
get us hurt
[Music]
[Music]
it's on the all my sisters oh oh that's
a good sign he's walking up come on yes
you know
we good yeah you can walk we good nah
[ __ ] if you could breathe you good
you could breathe oh hell yeah it's on
the bengals but here's the thing
that deepens the line it's something
i'm going to say roughness
here's the deal people look at this this
is von miller
that's not unnecessary roughness that's
just football mike no he hurt him too
bad no not necessary oh my goodness mike
you can't even fight you can't play
football in these times
not that bad the guy mike is right it's
a 16 billion dollar industry don't hurt
the quarterback joe borrows the face
mike is right they can say well they
better hold these guys man whoa
here we go
all right man you know what i don't like
that bee i don't like seeing o'dell on
the sideline no it's not gone
man uh but he came back
yeah
so here here's the deal folks right now
with joe burrow's feeling
you think
my career is over or this game is over
and then once the pain subsides and
you're like oh i can still do it that's
[ __ ]
in the next 10 minutes if joe burrow can
finish this game you better put him in
that facial expression so with that
initial reaction
it's like that pain is so tough you know
that
and then you're like [ __ ] you think as
an athlete my career is over the game is
over that adrenaline gotta carry that
drill yeah you know
it's gotta carry him it's a super ball
you gotta try to finish it you have to
and i guarantee you joe burrow's a
gangster guaranteed doesn't sit out
it's like what happened to me and you
were fighting
yo
yo put me in the choke yo ass will be
asleep
you think so i would do it you remember
hey how many how do you think i'll last
[Applause]
i would say 35 seconds rachel i would
shoot you something you rushed
i would grab i would shoot at your legs
yeah 35 seconds but you're not going to
catch me
oh so that's what i said it doesn't
matter how long you're going to run so
okay you shoot up my legs you're getting
my legs in what's going
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro you feel like oh my god take that
seven seconds and you just go to sleep
that's it you go to sleep bro you just
did that and i said oh my goodness
he goes in your neck
like i felt my damn what is this called
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like this yeah it's all technically
so what's that what's what's my play if
i forgot get me there you gotta fight
your hands
you gotta fight two on one chin now
chin down fight the top hand
is this one they can't let my hands you
can't let my hands lock baseball bat two
on one yeah two you want to go there
with one arm who's the best uh
at grappling and who's the best i've
been out of it i beat him to my mind i'm
tired though but he's retired
right now
islam
he's just like habib oh charles oliveira
charles oliveira do bronx there you go
if charles oliveira gets your neck it's
over
look look that's why you always see
muscle memory you put that guy i got a
small little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
too
he just hey dc just put a choke on me
and it might be like two seconds he
asked me like he said put the choke on i
gave him a little taste mike he went
like that
he's the [ __ ] master kiss
[ __ ] the joke yeah and the man
he likes he likes playing
i do you like me yeah he enjoys pain but
don't do it in a bad way like i'm so
freaked out
i like that's in sport and sports like
i'm able to push through
whatever
you you want to get in the ring you want
to go 12 rounds i'm going 12 rounds hey
you know what if you want to go to ufc
in three freaking [ __ ] ass rounds
the first 30 seconds of those [ __ ] ass
rounds didn't pass out
against dc
no no i'll give you my journey
two rounds out last with dc two rounds
two rounds ten minutes
dc here's the thing you might drop it
i'm not afraid of you putting me out so
i might knock you out
because oh man i like your hey
[Laughter]
that's like me trying to guard you on
the football field no it's not it is
it's a fight
it's like me trying to guard you in a
football field mike tell him it's a
fight
i can't i can't believe that we're doing
this on television
me neither you might think about this
mike i can't go on a football field and
chase him to not stop and make a
touchdown he's going to make a touchdown
man-to-man coverage i can't stop you
you're going to destroy it but you're
telling me that you can go inside of an
eight-sided octagon and go ten minutes
with me no
but the best some of the best fighters
in the world haven't been able to go 10
minutes that's right but you're going to
do better than them yes
you're crazy i like your confidence
because it comes down to mindset listen
you know what you all know you are it's
because your mind is strong but knew i i
know i can't guard you in that football
field bro no but in fighting
yeah and fighting yeah no not about
taking a punt it's about
you say this about this no no it's not
everybody
everybody's a champion until they get
punched in their mouth let me see that's
it be martial michael jackson's out
when you get in that ring any kind of
fight when you get in that ring you
think you're a tough guy and you try to
get in that ring you better be helped
you better be careful no fourth dead of
a heart attack [ __ ] they get tired now
like what do you mean they get tired now
as soon as you come in the ring the
presence in that ring is it's
like
mike hey the way you're hey when you're
out there it's like walking in the wind
getting in there
[ __ ] everybody watching you i like
playing in front of seventy thousand
dollars
four million lives but it's not all mine
you'll be marching
up how many more three players when we
go out every march we're in there with
no clothes on we're not underwear
fighting
barefoot you as bear you as you are as
better today in the world make the fight
no shirt make the fight enough talking
marshall talking beat marshwatch
make the fight make the fight make it
happen now
make the fight
for two years i'm retired for two and a
half it's it's even gonna start saying
please i'm sorry you know that [ __ ]
mike
sorry about what you need how many meals
you need tell mike what you need right
now you're gonna start you're gonna
start apologizing everything mike oh
hell yeah no no no no no
he's gonna say can you teach me that
tell them
i don't know what you want you know what
i don't want to do it why i need to do
this
then i feel the obligation
then to go and try to guard you on the
football field and i'm not going to be
embarrassed
it's not that exactly but you fighting
me it's not fair in the octagon it is
[Music]
i don't understand this
dc
camera look at his face he's actually
serious
what is that just
shake shack oh i can't what is that
what is it i thought i thought you're
saying more whiskey on ice
that's what this guy wants yeah i can't
hey
you know what i would love to do though
for real
i'd like to match you up with somebody
else no no no no i just want to come
just mess around logan paul like you
know what i'm saying come here
respectable come to the gym and we just
i have to absolutely go to the academy
i love i love wrestling yeah but i've
seen i could tell that you've done a
little bit of boxing yes yeah your job i
can tell right away from the moment you
have yeah you're moving tonight you've
hit me you know where i won i went to
[Applause]
and then like t.o because he like i feel
some type of way all right
yeah and geo would be down i just i did
a show with him probably a month ago
he's in shape too of course too yes
thanks brother's down that would be good
one we can watch that
hey tio is in shape
yeah bro
i did a podcast with them
i can't eat those thank you i need you
might be drunk
championship rounds damn
[ __ ]
first
[Music]
they picked up seven yards now you got
this one second
we're talking about time and possession
control the clock
control the clock yeah we're in the
fourth quarter
that defensive line is built to rush
run the ball let's go come on get it
come on
yes
[Music]
that's right it's still manageable
[Music]
hey b marsh really wants to fight trello
somebody get [ __ ] up on mike tyson
we're about to get
hey mike come to tv mike
mike mike come grab them
mike don't want to deal with brandon
yeah i can't do this
dogs
mike's i can't believe they're paying
this [ __ ] ding ding yeah
the people want mike tyson back
you better hope mike don't learn to kick
but that's nice fourteen be marching
[Music]
once he gets mad it's over i got him now
he's slow
you don't want his problems
no bro
you don't want those kinds of problems
nothing to double that figure out one of
the greatest heavyweights of all time
and ufc
doesn't matter yeah like mike tyson
doesn't matter it's just like this joe
nixon
is willing out on joe mixon let's go
baby underdogs we've been to underdogs
our entire life let's go with two second
down yeah a lot of the fourth quarter
seven minutes to go it's 16 to 20. what
are we going to do you got matthew
stafford sitting on the sidelines saying
oh my goodness i've been in detroit for
twice
what happened
here we go
you better chill man all right
there ain't enough tequila in the world
it'll be marshmallows ain't got enough
to keep marshall i don't like this push
hey
leave iron mic alone
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey
you better chill bro be marsha about to
learn the hard way
let it chill
we got our mic
we got our mic i thought mike that
should be the problem
b
dc we got 19 keys here
it's another one we talk about money
lying
we talking about we're here to roar
what's up brother
the chain's dope dog you're changing we
got 19 keys one of the guys in this
space right now that's educating our
guys bro
we talk about these dudes right here
making
a crap ton of money how would you advise
them to watch the game though
you know when we look at statistics and
we look at nfl players we look at
athletes we see a lot of them lose their
money
[Applause]
learning how to keep your money and
advance your money to the next
generation is the key
so whether you got to put in
diversification man you gotta put your
money in ft's put it somewheres go make
you some money in the long term you
understand me that's the game that we're
supposed to play you got to have a trust
set up gotta have an estate setup it's
just interesting
right because it's interesting when you
think about money lying they do nfts
crypto yeah every platform where you
want to bank with them you can do so
many other things so it's interesting as
you say that
nfts talk to me about nfts talk to me
about crypto well it's really just a way
where we can get to on our own you
understand me where you look at
historically systems of control and
manage your money now you get to manage
it for you or you get to manage your
career where if i'm a nfl player i'm
gonna go ahead and take my image and my
likeness and find a way to capitalize on
it outside of my contract and there's a
lot of creative ways that a person can
do that outside the business you
understand me but that goes really for
any and everybody it's one thing to buy
into cryptocurrency nfts allow you to
earn cryptocurrency and if they're gonna
be the money in the future
say that again it's one thing to buy
into cryptocurrency you understand me
but it's another thing to be able to
earn cryptocurrency and if crypto go be
the money in the future then we got to
be tapped into the digital revolution
the dollar is consistently going down
inflation is very high so we got to make
sure that we not only have financial
literacy but financial liberation
sit with us
so we're here super bowl 56 you got the
los angeles rams the home team for real
playing against the cincinnati bengals
the game is legendary we got a couple
minutes left six minutes seven minutes
left in this game it's going to go down
as one of the greatest games ever i'm
telling you right now i don't know if
odell beckham jr is going to go back in
the locker room and put on the suit i
don't know that but what i do know is
the chair the heavyweight champion of
the world
okay has a lot of money on the line yeah
i have 19 keys here that's educating us
while we're watching the super bowl
love you
stay right here launch one second
breakdown that's b that's dc
dc
you know you know 19 keys
you would just introduce them to us
hey we're gonna i gotta go to the
bathroom we're gonna take you guys
on a big level i know man what do you do
with
uh i don't moneyline
anything with them man i'm a thought
leader so i usually teach those who
teach everybody else
i got my own platform
you know we speak truth to power and at
the same time i teach people well master
mindset but also how to utilize this
technology
you know it's it's great to see like
young people
actually you know what
young people like starting to
be more involved in terms of leadership
it's all about knowledge too that's why
this isn't a push of money line but i
think about money line is they have
original content educating people like
oh you want to buy your first car or
yeah you're buying your first home or
you want to you know your personal
trainer that's how you make the money
just have to hustle
yeah but how old are you 31.
so when we were kids there was they
don't teach you that in school they
wouldn't know what's going to finance
your taxes like how to make money i mean
i didn't have any of those things as
well that's why i just had to do
self-education yeah
self-education is a new harvard you
understand me yes sir because we all
went to school and got the wrong
education then we had to relearn and
unlearn everything they taught us in
order to do the right thing and then the
outliers figured it out but now those
outliers can educate the young yeah
well you know like wealth is a buzzword
but at the end of the day
if we all teach wealth i teach family
first you understand because meaning
ain't no wealth unless you can pass it
down yes sir you understand me
i don't do business without family you
understand me those are the dynamics
that we set up and then we teach people
skill sets to buy assets you understand
me i'm not telling you to just go get a
job i'm gonna teach you a money skill so
you can do for self at the end of the
day i just look at the leadership that
we've had historically throughout the
past and i try to figure out if i can
stand on the shoulders that we can go
further and if i got that blueprint why
wouldn't i be able to yeah and we got
phones and technology so we ain't got no
excuses no the information is it's on
you to figure it out it's available i
mean y'all fighters so i look at the
league
of that and i always look at every place
and i say okay how could you advance
that and how can you take everybody
complaints and instead turn into a
business model right so it's like
attention is what allows platforms to be
able to convert that
but now you've got the ability to create
your own platforms and monetize them you
got the business acumen you got the
skill
but when you can merge those two
together then you got everything you
need everything you need
really you can do it all from your phone
you really can't should i've been did it
all for my phone there's no excuses none
of people put excuses in front of their
opportunities yeah those nice necklaces
too huh yeah you know i'm just an
investor man i'm about just to go i got
one
i got one i need a [ __ ] my [ __ ] looks
weak right now i'm only worried all the
time i just this this uh
my spiritual mentor so i'm gonna keep
that on my neck at all times because you
talk the economic blueprints of black
people in america so i'll keep that and
then i always wear my crown and
represent knowledge itself
so everywhere i go i gotta be a
reflection of what i stand for my man
well said bro
fourth and one
but if i can get y'all on the show one
time and i love it as well just sit down
and have a high level conversation we
got this weird listen now we don't got
this weird [ __ ] here right
yeah pretty much when i took a [ __ ] he
went to the bathroom yeah champ he went
to the bathroom champ well you've been
in a hot second though
champ don't hey champ we got four
minutes left don't get him before we get
on there don't get him on here
i've been through that i
i got tired of getting the
lawsuit broke me down yeah
they broke me down i bet they were fun
though
they broke me down
champ how you got to shape like that
how you got in shape like that you were
heavy for a while
you got in shape like real shape i did
um
not running
blood
spinning you still run jam
yeah i did blood spinning
okay how did that work the blood
spinning they take your blood out
you are fitting it all up
that bonus
put it back in and that's the noise
build up the energy in the blood i'm i'm
what they call it again it's called prp
prp but another word
they call it another plasma plasma
replacement yes
stem
cells
and that's how you got in shape though
yes you running like mike
yeah on the treadmill
i bet you i bet you're huffing for them
good
jim you spar still are you just trying
to hit fast no i just hit the back but
periodically
you can't run every day like you used to
because it starts breaking you down
you're hitting back everything
so now you got to take two days off and
come back
all right we're playing now right come
on mike you're nervous about your money
that's right you nervous about your
money
no you're good hey mike whenever you
fight no young y'all run a mile for
every every round
a mile per round
no um
12 hours nobody got paid more to spar
with me no i'm saying like when you were
running on your road work yeah did you
want one mile for every round for like
12 miles no i did i ran 20 miles before
20 miles yeah i did a 20 mile before
that's that road work
that's a real road work go cool come on
get this guy that's receiving the nfl
mango keep on the beds max
look at all these people rooting for
these people man
so right now we're getting into
situational l.a locals gonna stick
together you feel me situational
i got to clear out my distractions
i gotta focus on the situation at hand
oh no
boom we throw it down mr relax our
second down and manageable okay
we're in the red zone there's so much
going on right now they're trying to
score this guy trying to score
of course
mike what do you want right here do you
want to last or do you want to run
i don't know they putting pressure on
the bango you gotta it's only two that's
it you can pass where you can run that's
it
what do you wanna pass it pass it all
right
it looks like it we got three by one got
one run back in the backfield they
choose to run so they didn't
you're a money guy yes sir how much
money is being spent
or what's going on right now in the city
of los angeles because the super bowl is
billions
it is in the billions right millions
like you wouldn't believe it i mean they
just said
it might be tens of billion we a we got
a we got a spending problem everybody in
the mayor got a spending problem well
it's inflation right now though i know
but we need to have an investment
problem you understand me that's the
solution is like they put out there that
black people got 1.6 trillion spending
power but we lost 14 of our net worth
it's because it's spending meaning it's
going out if you circulate it you're
coming back to poor origin if you invest
in this giving you a return on your
money
invest in real estate probably the
safest place not just real estate right
now real estate probably gonna have a
bubble for everything that's going on
it's very high you understand me uh but
you got crypto you got gold you got nfts
you got blockchain technology you
understand you got stocks right
historically stocks and businesses go
get you the best returns but now you got
crypto if you know how to invest it in
the right way and then after all this
regulation happen it should be good at
least when you're looking at the time
it's not going to work
we have to look at the reality too
everybody's not going to get rich
percentage is not high in that
perspective but that's why it's like if
the average person just invests 500 or a
thousand in bitcoin if it continues to
go up this way you will be all right
there's not enough bitcoin for every
millionaire to own one
you understand me so you don't have to
have a lot before standard of living in
the future you gotta hunt something it's
about education listen if you have 500.
i don't know anything about this but i
have it
i know see that's the key there you go i
don't have smart people around you who
help you out yeah
i don't know if it's gonna be worth
anything if i prepare for the future
even if i don't know what it is well
sure the only key against the risk right
now is diversity so you gotta invest in
everything that's the only way it's
gonna work out that's what your money
matters is that's not the rich that is
the wealthy richest frame of mind you
can have a billion dollars and be poor
yeah
you know yeah i mean you know i look at
welfare's the abundance mindset
if you balance you can go in the
negative you can go into positive but if
i'm abundant i got enough to give away i
know but wealth is the value that you
have in yourself i'm not wealthy you
know i mean because i'm valuable i'm
valuable because i'm wealthy well see
that's in the mental aspect but in the
power aspect remember your ability to be
able to move power and energy
collectively like that's not even that's
rich you know in order to guide you the
rich didn't get there by saying he went
through it from the mental perspective
absolutely mentalism is key i develop
it's the precepts every everything in my
mind that's what my womb is that's why i
give birth but then i'm gonna work it
into existence that's my formula
so i teach people to mindset eighty
percent mindset twenty percent skill set
but if you ain't got the mindset you
ain't gonna never develop the skill set
to execute
you and someone listen
i don't have the mindset well back then
when i was the young i don't have the
mindset right but you got belief yes and
i have and i have the money no uh i
don't have to educate you i have nothing
money your sister uh jackie told me some
great stories about you when you were
younger so you always had a vigor you
mean to believe in yourself or energy
where you gonna go forward regardless
people don't i think you converted that
different i want to be up more than
anybody wants me to be down yeah and
there's a lot of people that want you
down in here here we go b-mark it's not
gonna happen oh it's wide open
listen this is gonna be the bingos okay
we're in the red zone
everything's about numbers the numbers
game right now is not favoring
but los angeles well you got four plays
right now the rounds about to score
they're gonna go up twenty three this is
the rapture he's gonna start cheating
for them this is what you gotta do to
see what josh mcdaniels of the new
orleans patriots
that quarterback got to get outside the
pocket and receivers got to keep running
to actually score a touchdown
keep moving watch this boom
that's the pressure
pressure
why why not five yards well what you got
to understand is these dbs don't have to
backpedal not right now
they can sit there at the goal line
people remember the back in line is
their friend another defender how many
throws do they have left
they got two they got third down they
got fourth down mike tyson
okay is asking brandon mikey because
watch this running back picking up 10.
watch this running back
no
that's [ __ ] right that's [ __ ]
that's both getting bald that's all yeah
they're gonna get him on the left arm
mike i think they're to get him on the
left one
left right away so that's all
this guy don't even look right
he don't even look right dude he ain't
down for our pizza
that dude look like larry ellis
wilson's been playing a phenomenal game
let's see if it's look look look look
look look oh you can't do that we can't
i can't look at this
hold on timeout is it within five yards
nope if it's with this stop it's not
it's not all right then it's a penalty
mike that was a little referee man it'll
be good
we're going hard
and still get
oh he's talking [ __ ] he got lit up he
got mint up can't
[Music]
because 70 of the time mike when you
blitz matthew stafford touch he converts
seven is your target number that's real
those that's that's learning that's
understanding the game seventy percent
of the time teams who blitz matthew
staff that's the best i've been like
man cooper cup eastern washington yeah
but he got him in the face while michael
kiev loved hang on watching me dude
oh
[Laughter]
mike talk to us about now talk to us
about branding and
like marketing and marketing
yeah
you are your brand is who you are
my brand is not me i'm the brand
so i have to represent my brand new web
in in order to accomplish what i want to
accomplish to be the best in the world
of what i do
i got a question for you i always kind
of wondered about this you remember that
thing you used to wear was like that cut
towel yeah was that your idea was that
something you guys thought of like the
guys in the 20s and 1915 used to wear it
oh really they didn't have roads back
then i always wondered why you wore that
it was [ __ ] cool
i ain't short shorts that's a great
question why says short shorts
check the bill
oh the left
the less clothes you have on the more
people come yeah dude that tall thing
was like explaining because i remember
when you lost that brand explain that
less clothes we have on them
i know but explain what i mean
we're over sexualized
everything sex we look at yeah that's
the fact that everything everything you
look at well i don't like the [ __ ] that
wow
wow i hit that with nobody knows you
know
my whole life is sexualized mike know
just look at the halftime look at the
halftime show mary j blige look yeah
look at the people dressed in here
hey mike when you order one when you
wore the towel and tupac walk you to the
ring that's the most iconic ring one of
all times
when he was coming out with tupac
walking to the ring in vegas most iconic
ring walkers of all time still what made
you say i walk by eat your babies
because i wanted to
i've
no neighborhood more dangerous than up
here
[Music]
who is your favorite arena mgm or
mandolin madison square and man mgm
right got so much history now yeah every
time i fought there you could feel the
history
like every time and then in the hallways
they got all you guys pictures in there
like from the big events yeah when
you're walking through the hallways to
fight you'd see a picture of you
yeah here we go
second ago when i was being four hold on
one second they're building an mgm
ground for me
back shoulder
back shoulder back shoulders back soon
mike smite cooper
that back
yeah that back shoulder is like an
uppercut yeah i'm here all night yeah
and then all of a sudden boom it gets me
it's sneaky it's sneaky yeah it's sneaky
he's the best
score 20 22
the best in the world though why would
they leave cooper cup like that i'm out
no time
left
there's a minute and 25 seconds yeah
you got smoking joe burrow
still wow
touchdown not even a field team
money line give me a thousand a thousand
dollars
right now right now smoking joe you got
it a thousand it's one my thousand a
year two thousand
what are we doing
no
this boy won odds
[Music]
yeah oh 100 percent right now it's going
to be joe's on the other side saying
it's overnight so fast
though not so fast that's the war going
on looking look at staff
yes oh my goodness i'm out of detroit
yeah world champion can you believe that
and you got your mark chase
first you got smoking joe burrow over
there
smoking joe is locking one up right now
yeah
yeah
that's your bill
we're giving another 25k away that's a
hundred thousand dollars we told you
moneyline ain't playing man
how do they how do they win the money
how they win the money down
the money line there was the last winner
right there it's the last one this is it
it's too late now there's a minute 25
left in game aaron johnson you won 25
000
be smart with your investments talk to
my man right here yeah man 25k increase
your chances of winning
[Applause]
shout out to moneyline thank you guys
okay
man mike what's the name in this dance
i have no idea bro what is it is that
greedy
that's what they do in cincy
no louise yeah lsu boys yeah louisiana
don't take that from us b
that's on jalen too that's just crazy
right now it's a good game anything can
happen right now man blue 32 hood hut
i'm throwing up side to the left sack
yeah i like seeing that
[Music]
i'll go straight up a thousand a
business plan you got a thousand i got
it down all right i got you guys
you better catch it come on come on
you can't tell your wife
you come over here
third and one mike third and one big
play
you the money man 19 keys money lying
yeah you know
what's the odds what's the odds well
i'ma tell you man the best thing you can
do right now when the game is like this
is take your money and invest it in
crypto instead
much better odds i promise i'm trying to
get a thousand from b morrison that's
freaking crazy that gave what made a
terrible bet smoking germany the
terrible number one thousand it's a run
[Music]
i don't know why they're running erin
i like a good fight though no opposite
if if if our fighters
if our fighters know that then why
doesn't our offense
look hey right here like the coach the
coach now
young head coach taylor fans
he's nervous for fans is nervous
yes it's the best it's still possible
[Music]
oh
[Music]
look at it mike look at that
one
look at him go to work mike oh my
goodness
shake him up
mvp what about 99 99
what are we doing 99 70 feet oh better
number than that is
tell the ceo of moneyline to his ass
over here
why don't we get a thousand dollars i
just lost it now what can happen they
can't do nothing no they can't do this
39 that's his bet that's all that's
marshall's bet tell the ceo not to pay
it for him mike i'm sorry mike lost 25.
no
five
okay it's okay he said
it's okay mike saddle what eight eight
nine that's michael don't like to lose a
lot of people
they
school for him yeah some people like
doing too much well i don't think you
should never spend more at any given
time winning five or ten percent of your
money especially if it's not an
investment
damn wow what a game though the boy
woodwork got a title 40 years old
he's 40 years old bro yeah
that was a fun game though it was a good
game
mike how you feeling out there man
you're sad about the 5k or not sure
i like to lose yeah
you just don't like to lose
a little bit
not even a little bit
come on
[Applause]
that's a big win
super cup mvp right
super tough mvp right now
bro he had several sevens two times a
thousand back
[Laughter]
i guess it's over
the show is over now right the show's
over moneyline thank you guys all the
winners congrats over a hundred thousand
dollars
listen you still download the moneyline
app they have great content on there you
guys it's a smart thing to do shout out
to moneyline shout out to mike tyson
dc
be mars thanks holding it down
love it i love you all
we're out we love you guys
go rams super top mvp
that was love man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
food
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you